est meurtri et marqué à vie.
Il n'y a que très peud'd'd'd'en,
mais beaucoup d'aînés,
des battan
qui n'oublieront jamais
le mois t t t t 2018.
Cette femme dit que
la guerre leur a touhéhéhéhé.
Même la terre est moins fertile.
Comme tant d'autres
villages dioioioioion,
Erneti a été complètement
détruit
de l'armée russe.
Elle nntntntntnte
que les soldats russes
les
puis ont brûlé leurs maisons,
s s s s se retirer, comme
ils le font aujourd'hui
"On sait ce que ça veut dire n i
juré est encore si près.
jamais vraiment parti. "La basee
est juste là, dit-il,
qui nous séparent."
Nous sommes à 200 mètres
à peine de la ligne de contact
deux territoires séparatistes
de la Géorgie que Vladimir
Poutine et son armée
depuis le conflit de 2008.
La gare a été brève,
plus de 1000 morts
et 120 000 déplacées
en cinq jours de combat.
Ceux qui sont resté
ont reconstruit. Leurs maisons
se distinguent des
avec leurs toits colorés.
Il vit seul, anxieux.
Une carte de la région tapissedt
il explique ce qu'il appréhende.
"Si la Russie gagne un Ukraine,
nous serons le prochain, c'estsr
la Géorgie, pour la Moldavie,
pour la Pologne aussi."
Il reproche à son propre
gouvernement de ne rien faire
et de manger dans la main
ses propres intérêts.
Il est à ce point dégoûté
qu'il irait lui-même
mais ses jambes le trahissent.
Au moins 2000 Géorgiens
son voisin, qu'on voit sur
cette vidéo qu'il a envoyée
du front.
Ce voisin est mort le 16 avril;
il avait 40 ans.
Cet homme est son cousin.
aller le rejoindre en Ukraine,
quand il a reçu l'appel
confirmer sa mort.ououououououo,
dit-il, il s'est b
contre les Russes ici,
en Géorgie, en 200
Tout le village est
consterné et monte la garde
devant la maison du défunt
à l'intérieur et il n'est
pas encore au courant.
La nouvelle va le démolir.
rapatrié pour le lui annoncer.
Un autre cousin nous invite
de se vider le coeur.
"Si l'Occident avait aidé
la Géorgie en 2008, l'Ukraine ee
aujourd'hui. Mais les Géor
se sont battus seuls.
(aboiements)
Nous sommes interrompus
padddddddddd
quelqu'un frappe au portique.
qui vient aux nouvelles.
Quelle tragédie.
(cocorico)
"On tremble de peur,
et on tremble de peur."
"Qui sait ce quea a a a a a a ?
Il faut l'arrêter", di
Il a le champ libre, d'autant
plus que l'Ossétie désésésésésée
de se joindre offi
à la fédération russe."
La dépouille du soldat
est arrivé samed d d d d d d d s
Géorgiens qu
sur une mine en allant
le récupér "La guerre est une s"
14 ans après la sienne,
la Géorgie se bat toujours.
"Notre ami est commun.
La guerre de l'Ukraine